hello and welcome back to the shaky sign
shape in this video I'll review the book
superhuman the bulletproof plan to age
backwards and maybe even live forever a
recent book by Dave Asprey so this isn't
Dave's first book but it's the first
book of his that I've read and I mean
overall I actually found it quite an
interesting read and somewhat
entertaining at the same time and I've
made various notes whilst reading it as
well and say the aim of this video is to
kind of just discuss through some of the
key points and key takeaways from the
book and to evaluate my opinions and
thoughts on it there were also a couple
of cringe-worthy moments which I'll save
until the end but yeah I mean generally
I did quite enjoy reading this book so
firstly what is this book actually about
well the book pretty much covers why we
age but also it covers more how to age
what are your first words backwards and
does that feel the practical advice and
say goodbye or hacking to manipulate and
prevents the aging process so then who
is Dave Asprey and why does he have this
information so I first heard of Dave
when reading an article about a man he
wanted to live to 180 and what this man
is Dave Asprey and to achieve this Dave
does Listerine biohacking a term that he
coined himself which refers to the arts
and science of changing the environment
around you and inside you so that you
have full control over your own biology
and for those reasons that's why he's
often referred to as the father of
biohacking but biohacking isn't
necessarily cheap and he spends his
money and invest in his health
effectively and this money comes from
his company but the point says he's
pretty much a human guinea pig trying
out different ways to manipulate his own
body to extend his lifespan and
obviously this looks very personal
because he get his own experience and
the kind of reason why he decided to try
biohacking in the first place and that
pretty much stems from his diagnosis of
having Hashimoto's thyroiditis and so
most of the science behind these
different buy hats is pretty much
unknown and so kudos to Dave for
explaining this and his own experiences
in trying the different buyer hacks and
if he didn't know that Dave Asprey was
the founder of bulletproof coffee you
saw
he will by the end of this book the
number of references I mean it's kind of
given that bullet proof is in the title
or the subtitle of his book and yeah
maybe some of the money too for these by
hacks would get back into his pockets
but at least he could maybe invest that
money and trying me by hacks to further
inform us of his findings and he also
owns the upgrade labs in Santa Monica
where many of these bio hacks can be
performed so because dave has I guess
more for non science backgrounds then
myself it's a very accessible book to
read because it's aimed at what I'm
saying to anyone really so let's address
the first big question then can we all
actually be superhuman well one of
obvious issue or concern is the risk of
overpopulation if we're all living to
180 years old but I mean Dave's opinion
is that if there's equal access to
education and health care
then there actually would be negative
population growth I mean whether that's
peaceful I'm on Cali certain at least
what time scale that would be achieved
they also don't know but it is
definitely worth mentioning and they
have a confirmed that they've mentioned
is quite a good point and that is anyone
who wants to be a cheap human being
quite selfish and his opinion is that
well to be able to do this you'd need
the planet to live on as well and so
sustaining our planet at the same time
is of high priority anyone who would
want to be a so-called super human but
the idea is that if you live that long
he could pass on your knowledge to
younger generations to advance the human
race and so can everyone be superhuman
well I think and I think Dave enforces
his opinion that are always that any of
us kids enhance our lifespan even of us
by a tiny amount just few small changes
within your life and some of these can
be done for free which will be discussed
in the book and obviously reading this
book reminded me of the recent book that
I read which was lifespan by David
Sinclair and so I think there's a little
bit of a flat but it's a very different
book to lifespan so let's go to it then
how does Dave Asprey reckon you can
become superhuman well broadly he says
the one thing you need to do is remove
the things that make you weak and this
is to avoid what Dave refers to as the
four killers
so this includes heart disease diabetes
Alzheimer's and cancer and these colors
are more the kind of killers of the
developed world as it ignores infectious
diseases but one thing that does link
these different colors together is
inflammation and that is something that
it's critical and kind of underpins the
process of aging which is reinforced in
this book porcelain David Sinclair's
book lifespan so within the book you'll
learn about how the guts microbiome is
tightly connected to heart disease and
also look at the impact of having a high
sugar diet and the link not only between
diabetes but also outside this disease
so how can you prevent the four killers
and become superhuman well you need to
prevent the seven pillars of aging and
so Dave uses this analogy to reinforce
the point that you need to maintain
these pillars
that's deteriorate over time and cause
the aging process and these different
so-called pillars of aging it's pretty
much a different way of thinking about
the different hallmarks of aging which
I've spoken about before so Dave's seven
pillars of aging includes shrinking
tissues mitochondrial mutations
so-called zombie cells cellular
straitjackets extracellular junk and
also junk that builds up with themselves
as well and lastly the seventh pillar is
telomere shortening so what can you do
to prevent the seven pillars
deteriorating what does they've do so
this is pretty much what the rest of the
book goes into and there's too much to
kind of mention all in this video so
I'll just highlight a few key things and
so first let's look at these zombie
cells which is better known as
senescence cells so senescence cells are
one of the hallmarks of aging as well
because they accumulate as you age and
what senescence cells are are cells that
effectively have stopped the fighting
but are still metabolically active and
so some of these senescence cells have a
senescence associated secretory
phenotype this ASP and that can be
pro-inflammatory which is the link
between some essence and aging and he
mentions in the book about Sarah lytx
which are drugs that basically in target
senescence cells to for destruction and
so you can have a combination of
and Kassadin or for CSUN which is found
in strawberries seaweeds and apples and
cucumber and in this paper they
identified it as being a sin or lytic
and by removing the senescence cells you
can improve age-related conditions and
reduce the risk of cardiovascular
disease and the use of Semih lytx in
mice and rats have extended their
lifespan as well so now let's look at
what he means by actual cellular and
intracellular junk well Dave basically
refers to as John Kyle's misfolded
aggregated proteins and so that links
with the loss of Proteus ASIS which is
another hallmark of aging and one
disease that is tightly linked to masada
proteins is outside mr. C's we get these
amyloid pizza and tell dangle aggregates
which is basically just miss faulted
clumps of protein and so one thing he
discusses is the efficacy of taking
vitamin D to prevent this miss molding
which is based on the research of Gordon
lifting who studied worms and found that
by taking vitamin D the worms extended
their lifespan which reduced the rate of
this miss folding so without taking
supplements an obvious way to increase
vitamin D is to suspend more time
outdoors and according to Dave if you
want to be superhuman it's best to do
this in the morning and that's because
of the stimulation of the circadian
rhythm by blue light and I like this
quote by the day that blue light is the
high fructose corn syrup for fighting
and it's true I mean the availability of
blue light late at night is what also
disrupts our sleep patterns and sleep is
very important for becoming superhuman
as we'll discuss later but lights isn't
only a bad thing it can also be a good
thing and he discusses something I
hadn't heard of before which is
ingenious lights therapy which basically
stresses cells and has a home attack
effect to stimulate the stress
preventing pathways in the cells and
this is by introducing UV light directly
into the bloodstream well I couldn't
really find too much information about
this so I don't I can't really comment
and how fact that this would be or if
it's safe so I would just stick with
walking for now but the second thing he
mentioned was infrared light therapy and
say more is known about near-infrared
light therapy as opposed to you
therapy at least what I could find in
the literature but I still don't know
too much about it and so I can't really
comment but I think it's something that
it does more interesting research I
think yeah that could be smart now I
don't really know at the moment but
Davis tried both these therapies and has
claimed that he is noticed benefits so
he knows another interesting thing he
mentioned is the importance of teeth and
this whole concept of neurological
dentistry in particular Dave discusses
how a misaligned bite can cause
continued activation of the to Germany
love which is like continual activation
of this the fight-or-flight response
which isn't good for the body and are
even the feminists much more to learn
about this and I think it's very
interesting but again you know you have
your teeth for life as well there's
something that you want to look after if
you were going to live to 180 and then a
big chunk of the book actually discusses
about diets and what foods you should
and shouldn't be eating she become
superhuman so firstly I feel like I
couldn't have a video about Dave Asprey
if I didn't mention the origin of
bulletproof coffee so according to his
website bulletproof coffee
aka butter coffee is an energizing
beverage made of quality fats and
high-quality coffee beans but why did it
originate from well it came from when
Dave was handed a creamy cup of
traditional yak butter tea fire kind
Tibetan women and having drunk adversity
he said it was delicious but more
important I felt like it brought me back
to life I was suddenly and remarkably
full of energy following this experience
they've been trying to reproduce this in
a way that worked for him and henceforth
came bulletproof coffee now I haven't
actually tried it myself so I can
actually comment on how energizing it
since I thought you know I'm sure you
could read this book or many offers
videos where he'll tell you all about it
so moving on the next thing we'll look
at is the fats in terms of omega-6 and
omega-3
now there's lots of contradictory advice
given a many different kind of diet
books about what you should and
shouldn't eat but here Dave keeps it
quite simple I'm simply you should eat
omega-3 fats and avoid a mucus expats
it's simple and it makes sense so yeah
it's all about eating the right
the facts now one interesting story that
Dave mentions is the origin of
cornflakes
by mr. Kellogg's and how actually
conflicts was developed to lower the
melody and to the effort was quite an
interesting story I had no idea about
this and it's due to the fact that
conflicts is very high in carbohydrates
and very low in fats and this is thought
to mimic plate and also the hormone
levels in particular for males
testosterone but guys are like conflicts
we may be blondes but they're brilliant
anyhow another big and very hot topic at
the moment with regards to food is its
relationship we've got microbiome so in
case you weren't aware we aren't just
made up of human cells we are full of
bacteria as well but these aren't
necessarily bad bacteria they are good
in terms of being able to break down in
particular fiber and other things that
we can't digest ourselves and so there's
quite a lot of evidence now that links
what you eat to what species of these
bacteria you have in your gut and so
prebiotic fiber is good for having a
strong microbiome because it increases
the amount of bifida bacteria present
and this bacteria has been shown in this
paper to be able to reduce the leakiness
of the clonic mucous layer which
basically protects your cells from all
these bacteria that are there doing
their good job so if these results can
be confirmed in humans there could
potentially be a future where we see
more frequently microbiome transfers to
alter the species that you've got
present so not only do you need to eat
well to become super human you also have
to sleep well and so I talked about
sleep and the video of the elf picture
that you just saw not too long ago and
reinforce the point that short sleep
predicts all cause mortality and so Dave
Asprey mentions some tips to help you
sleep better and also ways you can track
your sleep but he also says that not
only does how much sleep quality it gets
but also sleeping position is also
important and one of the best ways to
sleep if you want to be superhuman is
taking your sides see why well there was
a study done on rats where they found
that sleeping on the side improved the
lymphatic clearance which is the system
that removes junk effectively from the
brain and this happens whilst you sleep
well it is at least more effective while
she sleep and say this helps to remove
these aggregates of amyloid beta and
reduce the risk of outside miss disease
at least that's what is currently
thought it is currently still waiting
human confirmation so moving away from
sleep now and going to stem cells which
takes up quite a big chunk of the pic as
well as the stem cells simply ourselves
that continually divides and have the
potential to differentiate into lots of
different types of cells and it has
currently thought that stem cell
exertion is one of the main drivers of
Aging due to the reduced ability to
repair damaged tissue and so this is why
this much hype about stem cell therapy
which Dave has undergone I'm suing some
of his relatives at one story he
mentioned is a relative he had a damaged
heart valve that following stem-cell
treatment went to the doctors and adults
went you have no damage in your heart
it's gone you don't need surgery now I
don't know how many success stories that
are for these treatments or how safe
they actually are but they are available
if people are interested but at the
moment they are very expensive
so what alternatives can you do to boost
your stem cells well one piece of
evidence that Dave gives in the book is
that I think it's but that was fasted
for 24 hours should increase themselves
with generative ability so I'm just
going to whiz through now the last few
points that I made in this book because
it's getting quite long so you how to
prevent hair loss give yourself a head
massage because that's going to increase
the number of blood vessels and support
the grief of your retire cells how to
prevent shortening of the telomeres so
your telomeres are repetitive DNA
sequences that are found at the end of
your chromosomes that effectively are
like the she cups that remain the
integrity of the chromosome
however they shorten over time as a cell
divides and once the cell has divided
too many times such that the telomeres
are too short that it's dangerous for
the cell
enters replicative senescence so how can
you prevent shortening of the telomeres
so one interesting study looked at life
stress in females and their telomere
length and what they found was women who
had high levels of perceived stress had
shorter telomeres so I guess well it's
not necessarily easy but one way to
prevent that the shortening is to have a
less stressful life but also exercise
levels is supposedly a good way to
prevent telomere shortening
you can also buy supplements but again
that's expensive now the availability of
scientific support for Dave's advice
varies quite significantly between his
different practical advice but one thing
I will mention is carbon 60 which he
mentions quite near the end of his book
which in a 2012 study when rats were
given carbon 60 they found that the rats
had a 90% lifespan increase now this
kind of sounds incredible but actually
there was some mishaps within the paper
what up some duplicated data and
actually there was quite a small sample
size used in the study so it really I
mean you have to be very skeptical when
looking at data like this I'm saying
Dave those suggest that you could take
carbon 60 but there is very very very
little evidence for it
but if it is true then that is really
interesting so how to become superhuman
then well if we take a look at the
bottom line it's all about having good
feeds avoiding sugar having lots of veg
don't deep brain foods or Ang's olive
oil when you can color restriction too
as we discussed before in the lifespan
book having the right environment and
having moderates exercise and trying to
control your stress levels I have a free
meditation or other place so as I
mentioned at the start there were a few
cringe moments that I had when reading
this book one of which was I'm creating
here my home equipments grew in length
by more than 15% which took me about
three months to stop doing a double-take
when I glanced in the mirror so yeah I
mean a bit cringy but sometimes they
make the bogum
I'm stating so April this was a really
interesting book to read although I feel
like you have to take it with a pinch of
skepticism and caution because a lot of
it there is just a lot of lacking of
scientific data to back any of these
practical advices but for those like
Dave who don't really care too much
about it and if there's any kind of hope
we'll just go for it
then sure it's a really good book to
read and contains advice that could add
years to your life so as always thanks
for listening